Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Warum denn nicht? Warum meine Füsse runter vom Bett? Du bist in meinem Hotelzimmer, okay? Und hier gelten meine Regeln, du kannst nicht einfach die fucking Dreissigkeit von Leuten überhaupt ihre scheiss Füsse irgendwo hinstellen zu müssen. Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist, erst mal meine Schuhe ausgezogen. Ich fühle mich heimelig in deinem Hotelzimmer. Es ist schon ein bisschen seltsam. Die letzte Hotelzimmerfolge, man erinnert sich, war in Hamburg. Ja, das stimmt. Die war grauenvoll. Bei den Rocket Beans waren wir einmal bei den Rocket Beans zu Gast. Und jetzt sind wir wieder, jetzt sind wir gerade... Stefan, es ist so ein bisschen eine Interviewsituation. Stefan besucht mich. Ich tour gerade durch ganz Deutschland. Du hattest zwei Auftritte.
Und vom Tanzorchester und Stefan. Du hattest zwei Gastauftritte. Hat mal ein bisschen Zeit gefunden. Du hast den Stage-Time von zwei Minuten. Du hast mich irgendwie zwischen Auftritt und jetzt irgendwie noch Autogramm besiegen. Du hast eine Woche jetzt Pause. Ich muss ihm erstmal ins Gesicht gucken und sagen, wer war es, Stefan? Da hat irgendwas geklingelt, ganz fern und weit. Du hast mich umarmt. Und dann kam es wieder, ja Stefan, und Klar, für so einen alten Kumpel aus alter Poffo-Zeit lasse ich natürlich nochmal 20 Minuten raus. Man merkt, das Stage-Adrenalin schiesst durch seine Adern. Klar, stell mir eine Frage, was willst du wissen? Mein Name ist Stefan Tizardo, das ist Florentin Will. Ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich zu unserem Interviewformat hier am Donners Talk. Plutin, diese Tour, die sind ja auch immer so ein bisschen, zehren die an den Nerven. Das ist Stress, das ist pur, das ist Nightliner-Leben, man schläft nicht. Wie gehen Sie damit um? Nightliner ist ein guter Punkt. Die Frage ist natürlich, bei Nightliner dreht sich jede Intuition um. Normalerweise, du siehst Stockbetten. Wenn man rückwärts fährt. Du siehst Stockbetten und du weisst, das beste Bett ist unten. Und dann dachte ich mir. Warum? Weil man aufs Klo muss oder mit die Morgenlatte hat, will man nicht erst an Peter vorbei, der unten liegt. Ich denke mir aber auf der anderen Seite, der, der nach oben will, muss ja auf dein Bett unten draufsteigen. Nee, da gibt es ja die Leiter. Nee, es gibt keine Leiter. Keine Leiter im Nightliner? Nein. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, eigentlich ist ja oben besser, weil da wirst du auf jeden Fall in Ruhe gelassen. So, auf jeden Fall, egal wie die Logik ist, Nightliner-Logik ist nochmal ganz anders, weil es gibt drei Ebenen. Ja, und wenn es bremst und du schläfst hinten an der Wand, dann wirst du einfach in den Raum geschleudert. Ja muss man sich anschnallen? Wie so ein Torpedo. Ne, du musst dich anschnallen. Müssen sich anschnallen? Wie Alexander Gerst auf der ISS. Du musst auch die Hand so raushalten, wenn der Bus abbiegt. Wenn du blinkst. Du musst auch das Blinkzeichen machen. Und ich dachte mir erst, ja klar, unten natürlich, unten. Ich lag direkt über dem Motor, bei dem lautesten Teil des Gefährts und direkt neben der Lüftung. Also es war sehr laut. Ich weiß nicht, ich bin einmal mit einem Nightliner gefahren. Wirklich jetzt? Wir sind gerade im Florentes Hotelzimmer, das war kein Scheiß, weil die coolen Leute sind im Nightliner. Es ist ja auch gerade direkt nach dem Auftritt, wenn ihr euch fragt, was ist das für ein Rockstarleben, trinkt man danach, schnappt man sich die Groupies, beseucht sich, dann geht noch mal ein Grüner umrum,
wie wir coolen Leute sagen, ein Grüner,
ein Grüner und weißt du
und Lüden und dann und du bist
einfach direkt hier mit mir aufs Hotelzimmer
gelaufen. Ja, ich hatte auch ein bisschen Bedenken,
dass wenn wir durch die Rezeption laufen,
niemand auf den Eindruck kommt,
dass ich dich hier auf mein Zimmer mitnehmen würde, einfach so,
weil jeder, der uns kennt und der uns sieht.
Deswegen habe ich betont, dass wir zusammen sind, indem ich deine Hand genommen habe. Vielen Dank, danke, ich habe mir nochmal schon einen Snickers-Riegel geholt und er hat jedem versichert, dass wir jetzt festgehalten haben. Oh, mal wieder der Snickers, mein Schatz, habe ich gesagt. Ja, aber wie gesagt... Während ich ein Foto von Elektra vom Starlight Express wollte. Wir sind tatsächlich direkt, wir sind zwischen zwei Locations, die Locations, wo das Konzert war vom Neo-Magazin-Orchester und der Location, wo sogar Starlight Express draußen dran steht. Wir kennen es ja aus New York. Wie dran steht, das ist ja aufgeführt. Ja, aber wir kennen es ja aus New York, dass halt in einer Location verschiedene Musicals aufgeführt werden, halt die rotieren dann so und dann so. Und hier ist das aber nicht der Fall, hier ist das fest in Granit gemeisselt. Das Lustige ist ja, das ist auch so deutsch, normalerweise sind Musicals zwei Jahre an einem Spielort und dann in New York am Broadway oder so, erfolgreiche vielleicht sogar mal drei Jahre, aber dann war es das auch und dann verschwinden die und landen dann in Vegas und so und dann tun die halt so ein bisschen rum. Hier in Deutschland wird seit, weiss ich nicht, fast 30 Jahren, glaube ich, Starlight Express aufgeführt, so lange, dass es sich teilweise ändern muss. Die ändern teilweise Texte. Heute hat Jan auf der Bühne erzählt, der Papa wird jetzt eine Mama. Das heißt, das ist jetzt das Oberhaupt des Musicals, ist jetzt eine Mama. Der Eskimo wird jetzt ein Inuit. Man muss auch mit der Zeit gehen. So langsam, genau. Starlight Express bei der Starlight ICE. So langsam, man geht mit der Zeit. Man geht mit der Zeit. Bordbistro muss komplett überarbeitet werden, das ist ja komplett anders. Und die Songs sind alle Dubstep jetzt.
Es ist aber echt interessant, ich habe mich ja eingecheckt im Hotel und man sieht genau zwei Arten von Leuten, die Neo Magazin-Zuschauer und die Starlight Express-Zuschauer, das sind zwei ganz unterschiedliche Arten von Menschen und an der Rezeption. Die einen sind schwul und die anderen gehen zum Starlight Express. Ja, aber das ist ja so dieses Ding, ich dachte, dass ja Musical wirklich nur so ein Nischenphänomen ist,
wo dann jetzt vielleicht so die exzentrischen, irgendwie die, keine Ahnung, so die Fringe-Nischenleute hingehen. Gar nicht. Das scheint ein totales Massenphänomen zu sein. Ich habe so eine aufgebrachte Frau beobachtet, die gesagt hat, ja, aber wenn wir dann eine Stunde früher hingehen, kriegen wir überhaupt noch Plätze und so und dann eine Rezeption. Was ist das, Style Express oder Neo Magazin? Das war ein Neo Magazin, ja. Entschuldigung, das war Style Express. Sorry, Entschuldigung. Und der an der Rezeption, man merkt ihm an, dass er mit hysterischen mittelalten Frauen gut kann und hat sofort gesagt, jetzt machen Sie erstmal ein Foto mit Elektra. Ziehen Sie sich erstmal die Rollstuhl an, welche Größe haben Sie? Und der wusste ganz gerne, wenn Sie 15 Minuten davor sind, Sie haben ja eine Platzreservierung. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, das ist ein wirklicher Massenphänomen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es nur hier in Bochum so ist oder ob wirklich Musicals für die normalen Leute da draußen ein schöner Samstagabend sind. Ich glaube schon. Es ist auch hier so ein Kinderding, weil Zalexpress, das muss man auch sagen, ist nicht so ein Mainstream-Mainstream-Musical. Es ist so Mainstream-Musical, dass es nicht mehr ein Musical ist eigentlich, weil es dann schon die Nische verlässt und hin zu so einer, es ist ja auch so eine Spektakelshow mit Pyros, mit Rollschuhen, also alles, was man für einen geilen Nachmittag braucht. Und da gehen auch sehr viele Kinder hin und Schulklassen und so, ist ja echt so ein Kinderding, glaube ich. Vor allem, ich habe gerade einen Gedanke, wir sagen jetzt, ah,ide Express, das ist so altmodisch, aber gibt dem nochmal 20 Jahre und das ist halt Klassik. Weil Klassik ist ja auch nichts anderes als altmodische Musik, die überlebt hat. Weil ich meine, so ein Wagner, der führt das auf und 20 Jahre später so, oh Leute, jetzt kommt. Da fängst du ein Thema an. Mein Gott, Leute, jetzt nochmal die Walküren rät, Leute, jetzt haben wir es aber auch. Weißt du, da gehen dann 20 Jahre nach der Uraufführung von Wagner, da gehen dann die ganzen fetten Unterschichtleute hin, die Assis sitzen bei Wagner, aber wenn die, die entscheiden nämlich letztlich, was klassische Musik ist, weil wenn die lange genug ausharren, Wagner auf Rollschuhen, die Rollschuhen des Nibelungen, das wäre doch mal was. Aber wirklich, ich glaube, Starlight Express kann gut und gerne in 100 Jahren einfach Klassik sein, weil es einfach lange überlebt hat und irgendwann einfach vergessen, Scheisse ist. Aber dann bist du ja nicht Klassik. Du nennst es ja nicht um, weil wir haben ja jetzt schon Namen dafür. Denk doch mal in Millionen Jahre. Haben die klassischen Musiker gesagt, wir machen Klassik? Hat Mozart gesagt, was ich mache, mein Genre, haben sie gefragt, mein Genre? Dubzip, Klassik. Aber na ja, gut, ich meine... Was hat er denn gesagt, was er macht? Musik. Mucke. Ja, ich glaube... Orchesterstücke. Schwer zu sagen, halt so dann, halt vielleicht so die Art von Stück dann so ein... Messen. Quartett, Chore, Choral, Chorus. War das so die Musikrichtung? So, ich höre gerne Quartette. Wohingegen dann der Friedrich gesagt hat, nee, ich höre lieber Symphonien. Weil man kannte dieücke ja früher nicht, du gehst in den neuen Mozart und hast keine Ahnung, was da kommt. Und dann ist die so eine Geschichte von so einem Flügelmann, der irgendwie Leute in seinem Käfig einsperrt und dann pfeift der so, what the fuck, ey, früher, was war das aus dem alten Mozart geworden? Der hier so richtig mit hier, Carpe Diem und wie heissen die, O Fortuna und so, so richtig hardcore geiler Scheiß.
Jetzt kommt ja so ein Flügelmann, so ein bunter Mensch, so ein Küken-Typ vorbei.
Es muss eine riesen Enttäuschung gewesen sein.
Ich glaube, Ohrwürmer waren damals so frustrierend.
Ja.
Weil du kannst nicht nochmal ein Lied nachhören oder so schnell.
Oder dieses, aber wie heisst der nochmal hier dieser, und du kannst es nicht nachschauen.
Komm! Seine Frau hier ist Papagena. Wie kann sein Name gewesen sein? Papageno, Papagenas, Papagenat, Papagenamus, Papagenatus, Papagenant. Vor allem, der hat gar nicht, ich dachte ja, weil der hat irgendwie mit zwölf Jahren geschrieben, diese Oper, so ungefähr.
Ich dachte, der hat die Musik und die Texte geschrieben und quasi auch die ganze Theaterform darum, das Libretto, aber er hat nicht das Libretto geschrieben, er hat nur die Musik geschrieben. Er hat nicht das Libretto geschrieben, er hat nur die Musik geschrieben, der Musiker. Aber ganz kurz, Mozart wurde weiss geboren und wurde dann schwarz,
Michael Jackson wurde schwarz geboren und wurde dann weiss,
so rum. Genau.
Prinz wurde schwarz geboren
und ist schwarz gestorben.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es.
Ist nicht so leicht. Ich glaube,
jedes Instrument
muss sich erstmal gegen den Mund
durchsetzen.
Führe aus. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Nee. Weil irgendwie, jemand hat die Trompete vorgestellt, ein ultrakomplexes Instrument, du könntest mir jetzt nicht erklären, wie die Trompete funktioniert, Luft geht da durch, okay, aber warum wird da jetzt genau ein feines Gist draus, warum, weiss kein Mensch, so versuch's einfach. Und dann hat jemand gesagt, hier, pass auf, hier ist die Trompete. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, Kollege, pass mal auf. Ja, okay, das ist schon auch geil. Ja, okay, hast schon recht. Es muss geiler sein als der Mund. Oder in so einem Schlagzeug. Und dann kam die Gliedboxer und man hat kurz gedacht, Mund ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen geiler.
Ja, weil auch tatsächlich die Musiker, die auf der Tour sind, das ist ja absurd, das sind ja krass gute Musiker.
Wie schlafen die?
So viel am Platz. Haben die dann auch so musikalische Träume? Du kennst ja, vielleicht kennst du diese Flash-Mobs, wo man in so einer U-Bahn fährt und dann sagt einer und dann stimmen die alle ein. Und so ist es halt konstant, wenn du mit Musikern unterwegs bist, weil die haben alle Bock auf Musik und die können alle viel mehr, als sie bei dieser Tour machen müssen. Die müssen ja teilweise einfach nur irgendwelche Rhythmen spielen. Das ist unterfordert. Das ist unterfordert. Und deswegen spielen die konstant, es ist wie ein konstanter Flashmob. Und Flashmob, ich glaube auch so dieses da da da da da, du denkst dir die arme Sau, die einfach jetzt irgendwie Candy Crush auf dem Handy spielen will und einfach nur zur Arbeit fahren will. Flashmob ist für alle cool, die im Flashmob sind, aber nicht für die, die geflashmobbt werden. Und für die, die bei YouTube danach diesen Flashmob suchen. Ja, aber so ist es eigentlich, kann es dann mit Musikern unterwegs sein. Und teilweise, wenn da halt so ein Jam losgeht und der Posaunist hat es halt so ein Posaune nicht am Start, dann macht der halt ... Dann kannst du es auch lassen, wenn das auch reicht. Aber wie viele Flashmob haben wohl nicht funktioniert? Weil das Ding ist ja, bei Pranks und Flashmob siehst du bei YouTube immer nur die, die funktioniert haben, weil die müssen nachbearbeitet werden, die müssen gedreht. Wie viele Flashmobs haben nicht funktioniert, weil die an einem Ort stattgefunden haben, wo dann irgendwann Wachleute ankamen und gesagt haben, Leute, ihr könnt das nicht hier machen, wir müssen hier Platz haben oder sowas. Oder so einfach einer die ganze Zeit im Theatersaal und jetzt wir können die gesamte Tonspur nicht nutzen. Ja, die U-Bahn musste mal eine Notbremse sich halten und der ganze Chaos von König der Löwen ist umgefallen. Die Flötistin liegt am Boden. Ja, aber das habe ich mich noch nicht gefragt, weil es gibt ja so viele Pranks und dann denke ich mir auch, man sieht ja auch nur die, die gut funktionieren oder die gut backfiren, aber man sieht nie Pranks, die nicht funktioniert haben. Angenommen, es gibt eben so einen Prank, so zwei Kumpel sitzen irgendwie beieinander und dann verarscht der einen und sagt, ich glaube, ich bin schwul und stehe auf dich. Wie viele Pranks waren so, aber er hat vergessen, die Kamera aufzustellen, und dann löst er das so auf, ha, es war alles nur ein Scherz. Da ist die... Shit. Und dann kriegst du es nicht mehr aufgelöst. Ja, und dann bist du drin. Das sind absurde Situationen. Und neulich habe ich auch mal einen Prank gesehen. Da hat irgendwer, da war eine Freundin und ein Freund, und der Freund hat gesagt, ich habe dich betrogen. Ja. Und dann hat sie die Kamera gesehen. Konter die Kamera gesehen und hat dann gebackfired, heißt es, und hat dann auch gesagt, kein Problem, ich habe dich auch betrogen.
So, und dann versuchen aber beide jetzt den Prank erstmal aufrecht zu erhalten.
So, und dann beginnt so eine, beide wissen, dass gerade eine Kamera auf sie gerichtet ist, und dann beginnt so ein komisches Rollenspiel,
weil die guten Pranks da, die halten dann trotzdem durch und irgendwann sagen sie, Jesus, aber der hat es dann nicht geschafft und hat direkt gesagt, du hast mich betrogen, das war ein Prank und sie so, ja, ich weiss und dann entwickelt sich so eine ganz komische Dynamik, aber in diesem kurzen Moment zwischen, er bricht den Prank ab und hört zu, läuft so ein komisches Rollenspiel, wo beide wissen, dass eine Kamera auf sie gerichtet ist. Aber wie so eine Paartherapie, die nicht funktioniert.
Ich finde, man sollte ohnehin bei jeder wichtigen Entscheidung oder jedem wichtigen Moment seines Lebens immer eine Kamera mitlaufen lassen,
dass du immer, wenn es schlecht läuft, sagen kannst, es war ein Prank, eigentlich immer eine Kamera dabei haben, die muss nicht laufen.
Nur, dass du keine Ahnung sagst, willst du mich heiraten, Wir kennen uns seit drei Minuten. Hier, guck mal, ist die Kamera. Und dann, ah, toll. Apropos Prank, kleine Randempfehlung von mir, ohne darauf lange einzugehen, Long Mount Potion Castle ist ein Prank-Caller aus den 90ern, der viele tolle Sachen gemacht hat. Und der hat auch so Geräte, dass er während er Prank-Calls macht seine Stimme verstellen kann und auch so teilweise Effekte reinmacht. Und das ist teilweise sehr absurd und sehr lustig. Du hast gesagt Castle, jetzt kommen meine Überleitung, Castle, Takeshis Castle, Japan. Ich habe eine japanische Show gesehen. Geil. Und zwar diese japanische Show. Kannst du bitte, will ich deine scheisse Füße kommen? Warum bist du denn so? Ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, ich muss jetzt auf dem anderen Bett schlafen. Du schläfst doch eh in dem Bett, weil da hängt dein iPod-Ladekabel. Das ist offensichtlich, hast du die Seite gewählt. Du warst noch nie in dem Hotel, oder? Das Geile in dem Hotel ist, dass du während du schläfst, dich umentscheiden kannst, in welchem Bett du schläfst. Du kannst sagen, das Bett ist nämlich nicht kuschelig genug und du rollst dich um und bist in einem anderen Bett. Weißt du, das Erste, was ich mache, wenn ich im Hotel bin? Na gut, erst mal die
Gummibärchen auf dem Kissen essen,
dann den Bettschal,
wo ich keine Ahnung habe,
was das ist, nehmen,
Fenster auf, zerknüllen
und den Bettschal raus. Vor allem
Jesus Christ, wofür braucht man den? Gentleman's Agreement,
der Bettschal wird nicht gewaschen.
Gentleman's Agreement,
niemand weiß, was der Bettschal ist. Ist dem Bett kalt? Ich glaube nicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Im Ernst, wo ist der gut? Gentleman's Agreement, der Schal ist dafür da, dass er so dreckig ist, dass der Rest der Bettwäsche sauber wirkt. Dass man sich denkt, jetzt habe ich das dreckige, jetzt habe ich das, was hier so stinkt, entfernt. Und dabei merkst du nicht, dass eigentlich das gesamte Hotelzimmer stinkt, aber du kannst alles, das ist so ein Sündenbock.
Gentlemen's Agreement, wir schieben alles auf den Bettschal.
Hast du es gelernt, Gentlemen's Agreement?
Hast du heute den Begriff gelernt, Gentlemen's Agreement?
Aber auffällig auf die Cola-Dosen.
Du warst in Cola-Dosen.
Vor allem, woher hast du dieses Fachwort Bettschal? Was hast du gesagt? Hä? Bettschal hast du gesagt. Bettschal. Ist es nicht das Fachwort? Das klingt wie so ein exotischer Vorname. Es klingt als wüsste. Es klingt wie so ein Mitbewohner, mein Mitbewohner Bettschal. Es klingt, als wäre ich in den erlesenen Kreis eingeweiht, der weiss, was ein Bettschal ist. Ja. Aber ich darf nicht darüber sprechen. Gentleman's Agreement, man spricht nicht über Bad Charles. Es klingt wie ein misslungener Bachelor, einfach so. Der hat mir leider den Bachelor nicht geschafft, aber hier ist ein Bad Charles. Warum gehe ich auf die Comedy-Uni? Warum gehe ich auf die Comedy-Uni? Du hast eine japanische Show gesehen. Eine japanische Show gesehen bei Netflix und die ist wirklich weird. Schaut da mal rein bitte einfach. Es ist eine Netflix-Eigenproduktion und ich habe mal gehört aus Kreisen, dass Netflix produziert im Moment sehr viel in Europa und die kriegen ganz viele Konzepte aus der ganzen Welt zugeschickt, weil die ganzen... Jetzt wählen aber nur die besten aus. Wählen nur die besten aus und die machen aber ganz viele, die geben jetzt Milliarden aus für internationale Produktionktion. Und ich habe gehört aus dem Insiderkreis, dass die mit japanischen Einreichungen oft, und damit meine ich zu 95 Prozent, nichts anfangen können. Die kriegen, aus jedem Land kriegen die Konzepte, alle sind spannend, überall überlegen sie sich, was machen wir. Japan, keine Ahnung, keine, was machen wir? Der eine arme Praktik, der für Japan verantwortlich ist. Leute, ich habe Dinge gesehen. Und es ist wirklich der Grund, warum es noch keine japanische Eigenproduktion gibt, obwohl es ein Riesenland ist, ein Riesenmarkt, die nichts davon verstehen, die bei Netflix. Und jetzt ist das Ding, gibt es eine Eigenproduktion. Und zwar ist es, die Idee ist, es ist wie eine Schnitzeljagd, aber es sind Detektive. So, jetzt haben die, es ist ein Mordabend, die haben zu so einem Mordspiel sieben Detektive eingeladen. Es ist wie eine Reality-Doku gedreht. Ist Conan dabei? Es ist eine Art Conan dabei, es sind ganz weirde Typen dabei und die werden eingeladen zu so einem Typen, der veranstaltet abends zum Dinner und werden erschossen, im Spiel erschossen. Und dann müssen die diese ganzen Areale durchsuchen und sein Handy sich einloggen und so, um dann quasi die Hinweise zu sammeln. Und die führen die dann zu, das ist wie so eine Schnitzeljagd durch Seoul, ist glaube ich so Südkorea tatsächlich. Und das ist so abgefahren und das muss man sich mal echt reinziehen, weil die haben auch einen Humor, der ist ganz, ganz weird. Also schaut euch immer diese Sendung an. Und kann dann auch diese ganz vielen Einblendungen irgendwie mit diesem Manga-Mädchen und dann so ganz viel Pong, Pong, die sind nicht da, aber es ist unfassbar, teilweise wird es mit einem iPhone aufgenommen. Das ist eine ganz weirde Qualität, aber ganz seltsam. Schaut da mal rein auf jeden Fall. Ich habe da nur eine Folge von gesehen, in so einem Fiebertraum.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal genau reingucken und dann erzähle ich euch mehr davon.
Aber Insider-Tipp.
Wir gucken uns die eine mal an und dann reden wir nicht.
Wie kommt man da hin zu Netflix?
Was muss man anschauen, damit einem das empfohlen wird?
Ich glaube, ich bin durch.
People that like Breaking Bad hated this Japanese show.
People that have watched everything that is on here didn't even bother to watch this.
Everybody hates this shit. People that like Breaking Bad don't like you. They don't like you. Why do I come into this? I think if you scrolled down the whole page, du unten schon bei der Impressum, Kontakt und About Us gelandet bist, dann musst du nochmal zufällig auf die Fährbedienung kommen und dann landest du bei dieser Show. Warum habe ich nur 56 Prozent? Warum habe ich nur 56 Prozent Übereinstimmung mit mir? Ach ja, Hotelzimmer sind schon seltsam, vor allem, da gibt es auch immer dieses eine Ding hier, wo man seinen Koffer draufstellen kann. Ach, ich dachte, das wäre so ein Stuhl. Nee, aus wie ein Campingstuhl ist aber für den Koffer. Ich dachte also, um die Campingzielgruppe auch mit abzugreifen für so ein Hotel, die ja sagt, nur leh. Die hassen Hotels. Das stimmt ja, die hassen das wirklich. Nee, ich verstehe es nicht so richtig. Was findest du am besten an einem Hotelzimmer? Die schlechte Klimaanlage, die schlechte Kunst, die hängt? Ich mag das grosse Bett,
die vielen Decken und
die Freiheit.
Hotelzimmer ist für dich Freiheit?
Ich bin reingekommen, ich habe direkt erst mal den Fernseher
angemacht und der Fernseher hatte keinen
Empfang.
Je weiter ich gesappt habe,
desto schlechter wurde das Programm. Programm 1, 2, 3 waren gut, dann wurde es immer schlechter. Und ich dachte mir, geil. Einfach so, das sind so Erlebnisse, die hat man sonst nie. Du bist ja sonst auf YouTube unterwegs und so hast du plötzlich so Dinge wie lineares Programm erst mal. Dann hast du so eine Art von, der Satellit ist gerade, die ISS wirft gerade Schatten auf Bochum. Irgendwie sowas. Und plötzlich bist du so connected mit der Welt und denkst dir, wow, das ist schon... Wirst du gerne mal auf der ISS? Ja. Schon, oder? Ich kann mir das nicht richtig vorstellen. Das ist bestimmt ein ganz komisches Gefühl. Aber man wird doch schneller alt, oder? Nee, du bist schneller unterwegs. Wenn du sehr schnell unterwegs bist, die ganze Zeit alterst du weniger. Ja, aber die haben noch eine halbe Stunde für eine Umkreisung der Erde. Ja. Aber du alterst eigentlich mit den Tags oder mit den Sekunden, die vergehen. Ja, aber normalerweise alterst du ja einen Tag pro... Nee. Was dreht sich um die Erde? Mond. Einfach, Mond. Wie alt ist der Mond? Wie, wie alt ist der Mond? Naja, wenn du... Schon ein paar. Der ist schon ein paar Jahre auf dem Buckel. Wenn die Erde sich dreht, ist es ein Tag. Ja. Aber wenn du dich einmal um die Erde drehst, was ist es dann? Guck mal, wie schnell du um die Erde gehst. Aber... Ja, einmal! Ja, aber wie schnell? 30 Minuten, dann bist du genau dreissig Minuten gealtert. Aber du bist einmal rum. Na und ist doch egal, wo du bist. Du alterst auch am Saturn, geht trotzdem genauso lange wie auf der Erde, genauso schnell. Es kommt auf die Zeit an, die vergeht. Wie kannst du das denn nicht verstehen? Aber es gab doch mal so ein Ding, dass so zwei Zwillige reisen in so einer Rakete und der eine altert dann nicht mehr. Ja, weil der eine mit annähernden Lichtgeschwindigkeit reist, altert der nicht im Vergleich zum anderen. Das ist die Relativitätstheorie. Einstein! Ja, aber der, der um die Erde fliegt, ist doch schneller als der, der auf der Erde ist. Heute hat jemand Einstein widerlegt, sondern so ein Student... In U-Bahn mit so einem so ein Riesenschwein
so ein Student hat im Schlaf komisches Zeug geredet
und hat dann aus, was ihn Einstein widerlegt,
weil er so ein Spiel gegründet hat, was man dann spielen konnte,
und dann hat er irgendwie damit was bewiesen.
Und das war
und das war ein Artikel von Einstein,
er hat den Angry Birds
und dann hat er Einstein widerlegt
und dann gab es diesen Artikel
und dann habe ich draufgeklickt
Das war es für mich. Artikel von Einstein, den Angry Birds-Stahl, und dann hat er Einstein wiederlegt und dann gab es diesen Artikel und dann habe ich draufgeklickt und das erste, was ich gesehen habe, war so eine Werbung und dann gibt es so Artikel, wo man dann weiterklicken muss, durch so eine Bildergalerie. Und das war der Grund, warum ich diesen Artikel nicht gelesen habe. Und scheiß, vor ein paar Jahren, wenn jemand mir gesagt hat, die haben gerade Einstein wiederlegt, würdest du dafür durch eine Bildergalerie klicken? Ich sagte, ja, jetzt in einer wackelten U-Bahn habe ich keine Lust, mir das anzugucken. Aber vor allem gehe ich recht in der Annahme, dass die das machen, um mehr Klicks zu bekommen. Nee, ich glaube, damit du länger auf der Seite bist und die mehr Werbung unterbringen können. Aber du bist doch weniger, das nervt doch. Das muss dir doch auch klar sein, dass die Leute da keinen Bock haben. Ich glaube, im Verhältnis bleiben die meisten dann doch drauf. Aber ich dachte, das ist Klicks. Und man verklickt sich. Du verklickst dich ja auch. Also dann teilweise klickst du auf diesen Weiter-Button und wenn du einmal falsch klickst, bist du auf Tauchschule gelandet oder auf Karibikurlaub. Und dann... Du hast keine Luft mehr und dann bist du unter Wasser. Ja, und dann plötzlich klickst du dann drauf und dann kriegen die ja wiederum die für den Klick dann Geld von der Karibikfirma. Und ich glaube, das rentiert sich dann im Vergleich. Ach, ich dachte, das ist... Weil wenn du so auf eine Seite klickst, dann kriegt die Seite einen Klick, aber wenn du auf die Seite klickst und dann innerhalb der Seite noch dreimal rumklickst, kriegt die ganz viele Klicks. Ich nehme mir noch mal das andere Worte. Aber vielleicht läuft das auch nicht, ist das vielleicht auch gar nicht so wie YouTube. Das Wasser ist kostenlos hier, ich trinke das mal weg. Naja, wir kriegen bestimmt wieder ganz viele Mails, keine Ahnung, wir von gar nichts haben wieder. Apropos Mails. Ja, wir haben wieder... Also sofort, du kannst nicht sagen, apropos Mails und dann vier Minuten lang trinken. Apropos Mails und ich muss kurz einen Schluck Wasser trinken. Ja, was Stefan jetzt vielleicht gemeint haben könnte mit dieser geschickten Überleitung ist, dass er eine Mail bekommen hat, er hat eine Mail geschrieben vielleicht.
Es hat mir einer gesagt,
und deswegen, ich habe gesagt,
wenn einer das anspricht, dann werde ich es in der nächsten Folge ansprechen.
Wagner war ein schlimmer
Antisemit. So, jetzt ist es
vom Tisch. Und ich habe
gelernt, jemand hat eine Mail geschrieben,
was passiert, wenn Schiff untergeht.
Vielen Dank dafür, sehr interessante Mail. Und zwar haben die, das ist das einzige, was ich mitgenommen habe aus der Mail, schon so ein Protokoll, was man macht, wenn ein Schiff untergeht. Und zwar, wenn das Schiff merkt, dass es untergegangen ist, also wenn alles voller Wasser läuft, dann lässt das Schiff so eine Boje los, also so als, ich packe es nicht mehr, du schaffst es. Sorry, ich fahr ohne mich weiter. Ja genau, so ein Lass mich zurück Moment, wo das Schiff checkt, das hat keinen Sinn mehr, aber dann steigt diese Boje auf, die dann anzeigt, wo das Schiffswrack ist, also eine Art Grabstein im Grunde. Und das macht dann... Da ist Kreuz auch drauf, mit einem trauriger Smiley. Die Boje hat dann auch so ein GPS-Ding.
Einfach so ein ganz trauriger Mund drauf, ein trauriges Gesicht.
Hier, hier ist es.
Hier unten. Und die hat
dann auch so einen GPS-Peilsender,
so dass halt
der Kran... Google Maps, man kann direkt
bei Google Maps eingeben. Die werden doch ein Schiff
nicht bergen, oder, wenn es mitten im
Meer untergeht, aber dass man halt
weiß, dass es da war. So, und dann kennen die dann auch, keine Ahnung, dann und da geht auch so so Irrsinn auf. Ja, wir geben die Mail gerade gut wieder. Ihr merkt das schon. Nein, der hat gesagt, und da müssen alle auf Rettungsboote gehen, aber wenn das Schiff merkt, dass es untergegangen ist, dann lässt es so eine Rettungsinsel frei und so eine Boje mit so einem Jeep-Desender. Und tatsächlich hat er gesagt, dass der Kapitän immer noch der ist, der als letztes vom Boot geht. Ja. Schiff, sorry. Also der Kapitän ist der letzte, der geht, immer noch. Weil es sich ganz abgefahren findet, dass man da sagt, aber man braucht doch Kapitäne auf der Welt. Ich würde sagen, man sollte das nach Job trennen, wer zuerst geht. Ich finde, man hat wenig Kapitän, man hört selten, ich bin Kapitän abends auf einer Dinnerparty. Deswegen würde ich sagen, erstmal die Kapitäne runter vom Schiff, dann die Tänzer meinetwegen und dann die Friseure. Halt, dass man das so irgendwie trennt nach Wichtigkeit. Ganz einfach die Comedians. Comedians auf Kreuzfahrtschiffen. Leute, geht mit dem Schiff unter. Ihr könnt die Letzten sein. Und man lässt die Schraube an. Aber ist es dann auch so eine Nein-Sie-Zuerst-Nein-Sie-Zuerst-Situation, wo der Kapitän sagt, Sie können so höflich sein, wie sie wollen, ich muss als Letzter sein, sie zuerst, ich bitte sie. Da gehst du unter. Du kennst das ja aus dem Flugzeug, man soll erst sich selber helfen und dann den Kindern helfen. Und das denkt man ja immer, ja, was ist ein Quatsch und so und man wird das schon hinkriegen. Und ich mache mich auch immer ein bisschen lustig über die Leute, die dann diese Maske sich aufsetzen und dann mir zeigen wollen, wie man diese Maske aufsetzen, das ist bestimmt selbsterklärend, sonst wäre die ja anders. Die muss doch die einfachste Version sein, damit man in Panik das checkt. Und dann ging ja neulich, weil dieser Flug, wo das Flugzeug fast abgestürzt wäre, weil ein Triebwerk kaputt war, so ein Southwest Airlines oder so, A320, das ist das normalste Flugzeug der Welt. Im Zeitalter der Digitalisierung haben alle ein Handy in der Hand und haben aus dem Passagierraum gefilmt. Und dann kamen diese Dinger runter, die Gasmasken, und dann haben jemand ein Handy genommen und das gefilmt. Und dann Topkommentar, und später dann bei Facebook, ja, hi, hier spricht ein Steward oder keine Ahnung wie, ein Flight attendant, alle auf diesem Foto haben die Maske falsch auf und wenn er stickt. Ciao! Und ich so, bitte, was ist gerade los? Und dann guckt man sich mal genau hin, niemand hat die Maske über der Nase, die sagen immer über Nose und Mouth. Und dann sitze ich immer da an meinem Tomatensaft und sage, pfff, was soll ich mir da? Und gleich zeigt er mir ja noch, wie ich diesen Gurt aufbekomme. Gurt, so als ob er noch nie einen Gurt aufbekommen hätte, okay. Und dann zeigen die einem, wie man das mit dem Nose und Mouth machen soll. Natürlich ist es normal, ist auch klar, es war selbsterklärend, aber alle haben es falsch gemacht. Erschreckend, oder?
Dann lachen die mal, dann lachen die Sydalisten mal so, ihr lacht uns immer aus, aber wir leben noch, okay, und ihr röchelt. Ich würde zum Kind sofort die Maske vom Kopf reißen, in Panik, glaube ich. Auch wenn wir gerade bei Kreuzfahrtschiffen waren, meine Friseurin, die war mal lange Friseurin auf einem Kreuzfahrtschiff.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, die erste Frage war natürlich, ist es nicht scheiße gefährlich, wenn man dann jemandem Haare schneidet, wie so ein Rasierer und dann bei hohem Wellengang. Und dann meinte sie, ja, das ist teilweise schon doof. Und meistens, weil man ist ja, also Friseure sitzen ja hinter, also meine Friseurin sitzt immer hinter mir auf so einem Barhocker, so einem rollenden Barhocker. Und sie hat gesagt, es kommt häufig vor auf dem Schiff, dass man wegrollt vom Kunden, wenn man einfach zum anderen Kunden. Und dann muss man 20 Sekunden warten, bis man wieder zurückrollt. Und dann rollt sie einfach zum anderen Kunden und schneidet dann bei dem weiter, so Rotationsverfahren. Alle Friseure rutschen einen Kunden nach rechts. Und dann meinte sie, einmal war so hoher Wellengang, dass dieses ganze Haarspray-Regal einfach umgekippt. Auf den Kunden drauf. Auf alle drauf drauf und dann ist Haarspray und Haargel und so ist einfach alles ausgelaufen. Hat sich entzündet. Wo man dann auch sagen muss, ist das vielleicht der falsche Ort für ein Haarstudio? Ja, meine erste Frage wäre, wie regelt man das? Weil das Erste, was man ja macht, wenn man beim Friseur ist und dann kriegt man irgendeinen Scheiss in die Haare, man geht erstmal nach Hause und duscht sich und macht die Haare so, wie man sie haben will. Und wie ist es, wenn man auf engstem Raum der Person an 20 Minuten zwangsläufig wieder begegnet? Ah, meine Haare. Unweil. Ich bin aus Versehen von Bord. Hat Ihnen der Haar schon nicht gefallen? Nee, ich bin von Bord gefallen und dann waren die nass. Vor einer halben Stunde habe ich sie geschnitten und sie sieht anders aus. Ja, und dann bin ich ins Meer gefahren und dann das Salzwasser. Sagen Sie ruhig was, wenn Sie es anders bilden. Nee, nee, super, super, super. Dann habe ich das einfach gerade nochmal machen. Guck, dann mache ich das jetzt wieder, wie es vorher war. Nee, das ist doch kein Problem. Ich bin jetzt auch zum Limbo verabredet. Ist doch kein Problem. Ich habe das Limbo-Kurs. Sie müssen auch mit Ihrer Fackel nicht aufpassen. Das Haarspray ist ganz sicher auf den Regalen. Ist kein Problem. Ich war einmal im Leben auf dem Kreuzfahrtschiff. Und dann die Animateure, von denen kannst du ja auch nicht fliehen, weil das Deck begrenzt ist. Und du kannst halt nur einmal rum. Und dann kommen die mit ihrem Scheiß Wasserball, Wasserball, und du, nee, heute kein Wasserball, kein Wasserball, Wasserball, nee, ich bin auch gerade drüben beim Bowling verabredet, dann gehe ich einmal rum und dann sind die aber auch dann rumgelaufen und dann, sie spielen Wasserball.
Vor allem, ich meine, Kreuzfahrt ist ja teuer und ist für viele Menschen wahrscheinlich so eine Einmal-im-Leben-Sache so, das ist jetzt der schönste Urlaub unseres Lebens, wahrscheinlich viele Heimatanträge auf Kreuzfahrtschiffen. Und das ist ja fast noch schlimmer als der Heizhoffballon. Und Selbstmorde. Vielleicht hängt das zusammen. Wir lieben Kosta, Kosta-Kreuzfahrten, Suizid und Hochzeiten. Manchmal werden noch kurz für die Abreise Plätze frei. Aber vor allem, ich meine, Heiratsantrag, das das kriegt ja jeder mit auf dem Schiff. Und dann abgelehnt und dann, ja, jetzt nach zwei Wochen Kairo, einfach so. Und dann kam man nicht weg. Das stimmt. Und dann muss man ständig, trifft man sich beim Pingpong. Ultranervig. Und Kapitäne können trauen, ist das richtig? Ja. Bei Käpt'n Barbossa habe ich bei Futter E3 gelernt. Macht man denn eigentlich automatisch Schluss, wenn jemand den Heiratsantrag ablehnt? Oh, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Oder ist man dann noch zusammen? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, man ist dann getrennt. Naja, wobei, komm ein bisschen auf die Beziehung. Ja, warum? Offensichtlich führt es nicht zu nichts, Flo und Team. Naja gut, aber wenn man sagt, man ist jetzt vielleicht ein Jahr zusammen und der andere sagt, hey, man will einfach mehr Sicherheit haben. Wieso willst du mehr Sicherheit haben? Ich meine, es ist natürlich schon... Wie du willst mehr Sicherheit haben. So was heißt mehr Sicherheit? Es führt natürlich zu unangenehmen Fragen, aber ich finde es hart, dass man da gleich... Leute, Gentleman's Agreement, man ist nicht automatisch Schluss. Also Gentleman's Agreement, wenn ihr einen Heirat-Antrag macht und die andere Person sagt nein... Eine Woche Awkward Silence, aber dann alles wieder abgewohnt. So lange, bis er oder sie annimmt. Gute Frage, was hat denn die Knigge? Gibt es eine Beziehungsknigge, die mir solche Ratschläge gibt? Also ich glaube, das ist schon schwer, das nochmal davon zu erholen. Es gibt ja viele Situationen, wo man sagt, man ist glücklich, aber man will nicht heiraten, aber ich glaube, es ist schwer, davon zu erholen. Ich frage mich, ob das dann nicht automatisch eine schlechte Beziehung ist, wenn man nicht weiß, dass der andere jetzt auch Ja sagt. Man spricht doch darüber. Hm, schau, heiraten? Oder was? Glaubst du, allen Ernstes, Leute führen das Gespräch, angenommen, ich würde dich jetzt fragen, ob du mich heiraten willst, würdest du Ja sagen? Angenommen unromantischste Frage, die man stellt. Angenommen, ich würde mich jetzt hinknien, den Ring, den ich gestern, als du kurz mal tanken warst. Ich würde diesen Ring jetzt geben. Und wie war der Heiratsantrag? Im Konjunktiv komplett. Das war unerwartet. Aber sie hätte ja gesagt. Sie hätte ja gesagt, ja. Und das weiß ich nicht. Wir würden heiraten, theoretisch. Haltet euch schon mal, hieltet euch den 5. September frei. Es wird grammatikalisch, sehr anspruchsvoll. Ihr hättet geheiratet haben können. Unsere Band hätte Uptown Funk als Eröffnungssong gespielt. Ihr werdet geheiratet haben. Ihr hättet geheiratet haben können. Gibt es denn Future 2 im Konjunktiv? Wir hätten verheiratet sein können. Nee. Wir hätten doch Schluss machen sollen. Nee, unabhängig davon. Nee, Foto 2 ist doch... Du wirst Fussball gespielt haben. Ja. Du hättest Fussball gespielt. Niemand benutzt das doch auch. Du wirst Fussball gespielt haben. Das will ich jetzt nicht hinkriegen. Du wirst Fussball gespielt haben. Und dann wirst du geduscht haben. Aber dann muss ja was kommen danach. Aber welches Verb wird jetzt konjunktiv? Du wirst... Du wirst... Du hättest Fussball gespielt... Nee. Haben. Haben. Du hättest Fussball gespielt haben. Ja, das glaube ich passt schon. Wäre das Flugzeug nicht abgestürzt, dann hättest du Fussball gespielt haben. Wüsste ich, wie ich diesen Satz beenden soll. Wenn ich mein Grammatikbuch nicht verloren hätte, hätte ich... wäre ich gewusst worden, du wirst in Foto zwei eine Sechs geschrieben haben. Es ist kompliziert, es ist wirklich kompliziert. Aber ich habe die Erfahrung mit verpatzten Harzanträgen. Schreibst du die Kommentare. Ich meine, es nimmt ja auch ein bisschen die Romantik weg, wenn es keine Konsequenzen hat. Es muss ja schon ein bisschen all in sein, oder? Aber dann gleich Schluss machen. Wie gesagt, also um nochmal zurückzukommen, ich glaube wirklich, die Regel ist, wenn es die, wenn du wirklich überrascht bist, dass deine Frau gerade nein, Freundin dann, sorry, dann nein sagt und du das wirklich nicht wusstest und dann sollte auch Schluss sein, weil dann seid ihr offensichtlich nicht auf einer Wellenlänge. Also wenn die dann
sagt, nee, aber ich will doch
Sicherheit.
Ja, aber dann zwingt man ja fast
jemanden in die Ehe, wenn der andere
schon noch mit dir zusammen sein will,
aber nicht Nein sagen kann,
dann wird das ja Zwang.
Es ändert ja auch nicht so viel Ehe.
Das ist ein Label. Das ist ja eine Worthülse.he. Es ist ein Label. Es ist eine Worthülse.
Ja, es ist ein Label.
Label haben Wirkung.
Labels have meanings.
Labels have
meanings. You can't eat the
holes. It's a donut hole.
You can't eat holes. Es ergibt
mehr Sinn, wenn ihr Stephans Kleidung
sieht. Words have meanings. Ich habe gerade
einen Seinfeld-Poli. Ja,
in der Tat.
Es hätte mehr Wirkung gehabt, hättet ihr meine Kleidung gesehen und hätte ich eine gute Seinfeld-Impression gemacht haben können. Wenn selbst die Leute, die in dem Land leben, die Sprache nicht verwenden können, ist sie einfach zu kompliziert, oder? Das ist doch... Ich meine, der Duden bildet doch die Sprache ab, wie sie gesprochen werden wird.
Also warum denn dann... können, ist sie einfach zu kompliziert, oder? Das ist doch ... Ich meine, der Duden bildet
doch die Sprache ab, wie sie gesprochen werden wird. Also warum denn dann nicht gleich gewesen sein kann? Ich habe mit einem Amerikaner gesprochen haben können. Und dieser Amerikaner sagt zu mir, wenn ich jetzt zu einer Frau sage, kannst du das selber machen, kochst du selber? Oh ja, dieser scheiss generische Maske, in der es so macht.
Sagt man dann Selbe oder Selber?
Ja, ja.
Und ich so, das ist einfach so eine Frage. Natürlich sagst du selber. Ja. Pause. Ah, eigentlich doch eine gute Frage. Ja, total. Weil es natürlich total maskulin ist die Sprache. Du kochst selbe. Das muss eigentlich sein. Es ist für mich total bescheuert. Und das, also zum Beispiel, jeder, der Auto fährt. Also deinen Backstage-Pass abmachen, dass du den immer noch trägst und auch immer so zeigst. Und natürlich dreht er sich auch. Ich hab, wie viele As stehen da drauf? A, A, A. Warum A, A? All Access Areas. Weil jeder, der in den Backstage will, muss seinen Ausweis dabei haben. Und du bist Nummer? Sechzehn. Sechzehn. Seinen, du kannst es nicht anders ausdrücken. Sie muss seinen Ausweis dabei haben. Scheissprache. Naja, man muss sagen, es funktioniert schon ganz gut. Allein, dass wir uns unterhalten können über Dinge. Mir wurde gesagt, dass Englisch gar nicht so einfach ist, also vor allem, weil Englisch eine sehr einfach konstruierende Sprache ist. Und in dem Moment, wenn du sprichst, kannst du Wörter, also du kannst I like you, kannst du normal sagen, es kann aber auch sehr viel dahinter stecken, war schon so ein Ich-stehe-auf-dich-ich-liebe-dich-Ding.
Ja.
Und weil es einfach eine sehr einfach konstruierte Sprache ist, schwingt sehr viel Mimik mit. Und deswegen sagte man mir, sind Amerikaner auch immer, machen sehr viel mit dem Gesicht und gestikulieren sehr viel, weil je nachdem, wie sie Dinge sagen, auch noch sehr viel mitschwingt an Bedeutung. Und wir Deutschen, wir können uns sehr gut ausdrücken, heisst, wir können theoretisch einfach ganz normal einen Default-Blick haben und die ganze Zeit sprechen und man versteht unsere Stimmung, man versteht alles. Und deswegen sind Deutsche tendenziell eher nach außen den Gefühlskalt, weil einfach die Sprache schon sehr gut viel erzählt. Vielleicht auch dann zeitbeständiger, weil man ja so dieses ganze Zwischen den Zeilen und Kontext nicht mitkriegt über Zeit. Und wenn du in den Jahrtausend einen Text liest, dann hast du in Deutsch vielleicht eher die Chance zu verstehen als Englisch. Jetzt mal auf die Prämisse eingehen, die du präsentiert hast, der ich vielleicht gar nicht folgen möchte. Aber ich glaube, Deutsch funktioniert geschrieben
besser, ohne Emojis.
Ja, Emojis machen nochmal alles kaputt, ja.
Ja, Emojis
erklären ja auch, wie du Sätze meinst.
Wenn du den Cowboy-Emoji hintersetzt,
weisst du... Gibt's eine Kerze?
Ah, der Pokerchip.
Gibt's eine Kerze?
Jetzt kam der Zombie hinzu, wo ich mir dachte,
wieso sind wir denn darauf nicht gekommen, der Zombie? Ey, vor allem, es müssen Emojis weg. Das ist wirklich jetzt so, dieses Klassische, Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein Kerz? Ey, vor allem jetzt kam der Zombie hinzu, wo ich mir dachte, wieso sind wir denn darauf nicht gekommen, der Zombie? Ey, vor allem es müssen Emojis weg, ey, das ist wirklich jetzt so, dieses Klassische, das ist die Menschheit in der Nutshell. Mehr, mehr, mehr, mehr, mehr und gar nicht drüber nachdenken, dass vielleicht mal ein paar, so halt so Menschheit, so Population steigt und man denkt nicht drüber nach, dass mal so ein paar alte weg. Ja, und dann suchst du den Briefkasten und du bist am scrollen, tagelang am scrollen. Die Ker. Gibt's eine Kerze, weiß ich nicht. Weil es zu viele gibt. Man kann sich einfach immer neue Buchstaben hinzufügen. Jetzt gab's ja erst dieses komische geschwungene, diesen Baum, wo man auch gesagt hat, jetzt müssen halt irgendwie Ö und Ä weg. So, du kannst halt nicht immer irgendwie... Ö und Ä müssen weg für den geschwungenen Baum? Ö und Ä sind weg. Für was? Für diesen Bzzz. Bzzz? Bzzz,zz, ja, für Z. Das ist ja nicht S, sondern es ist Z. Es ist ein anderes, ein anderes, ein anderes Laut. Deswegen brauchst du einen anderen Buchstaben. Dafür sind Ö und Ä weg. Sausen. Einer kommt dazu, Sausen. Aber es gibt kein S am Anfang eines Wortes. Z. Es gibt kein stimmloses S am Anfang eines Wortes. Szenelischen schon. Szene? Ja, da ist ein Z halt dahinter. Szene, Szene eigentlich. Und das war's von Stefan Linguistik. Der Dudencast. Es gibt keinen stimmlosen S. Ja, wollen wir wir noch was über Hotelzimmer sagen oder? Ach, ich habe eine Badewanne. Ich dachte mir erst, geil Badewanne, dann dachte ich mir, ich habe dafür aber keinen Kühlschrank. Das ist ja wie so Sims, du hast einen gewissen Betrag für dein Hotelzimmer und dann musst du halt einsparen. Und dann hast du dir vier Lampen gekauft? Ach so, Lampen. Vier Lampen in diesem Raum. Viel zu viele Lampen, der Tresor. Warumresor. Die sind ohne Scheiß, du hast eine Deckenlampe, du hast zwei Wandlampen, eine Stehlampe und eine Stehlampe auf einem und dieser Raum ist nicht gross. Vor allem, ich denke mir immer so, also was mich irritiert ist dieser Tresor, weil man denkt mir sich so, wie sicher ist das Zimmer, wenn ich in dem Zimmer noch ein Tresor brauche. Er lässt ja fremde Menschen in dein Zimmer.
Nee, bei mir kommt immer sofort Karte rein, rein zur Tür und sofort bitte in die Stirn raus, sofort. Ich vergesse das Ding immer. Ja, das ist ganz wichtig. Dann kommen die morgen zum mal rein. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Daran erkennt man einen erfahrenen Hotelgänger, immer sofort bitte in die Stirn raus, ganz, ganz wichtig. Ja, immer rein, sich ausziehen, dann vergessen, dass man draußen das Ding hingelangt, dann nackt raus, dann das Do-No-Disturb-Ding zumacht. In der Zeit ist aber die Tür zugefallen und du stehst mal wieder nackt auf dem Flur. Ich glaube, ich hatte mal zu der Zeit, als wir die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse gedreht haben, da gab es ja eine Drehphase über drei Wochen, glaube ich, wo alle Schauspieler aus dem Ensemble, so zehn Leute, alle Apartments in Köln bezahlt bekommen haben und alle da leben konnten. Und er meinte, was er gesagt hat, alle Apartments in Köln, alle Apartments in Köln waren für den WDR auserwählen. Und ich hatte dann auch meine Apartments, das war wirklich dann so wie eine Wohnung mit Service, also wo einmal in der Woche jemand kam und eine Wohnung aufgeräumt hat. Aufgeräumt? Ja, auch aufgeräumt. Also es war wirklich, man hatte alles, man hatte Küche und so und da war dann auch wirklich so und ich habe halt nicht abgewaschen die erste Woche. Und du mit deiner Ü-Ei-Sammlung, mit einer Ü-Ei-Figuren-Sammlung, die dich immer um... Alphabetisch sortiert. Alphabetisch sortiert. Und ich habe halt nicht abgewaschen die erste Woche, und dann kam ich irgendwann montags rein und dachte mir, was ist denn jetzt los? Alles abgewaschen, mein gesamtes Geschirr war abgewaschen, und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ist das jetzt scheiße, wenn ich die Person in Abwasch machen lasse? Aber das war auch so, und dann kam irgendwie der Service immer montags irgendwie ganz früh, und dann habe ich halt teilweise noch geschlafen, weil wir nicht an jedem Tag gedreht haben, sondern manchmal haben dann zwei andere gedreht oder vier andere da und man hat selber frei gehabt. Und dann habe ich wirklich auf Papier außen dran geschrieben, bitte nicht reinkommen, bitte, bitte nicht reinkommen. Warum hast du Angst davor? Bis zehn Uhr. Was machst du denn da? Weil ich nicht während ich schlafen will, niemand in meinen Reinen. Und die sind jedes Mal trotzdem reingekommen. Warum bist du denn da so? Das ist ja auch für die Person mega scheiße, wenn die reinkommt und dann schläft da so ein nackter Fettsack im Bett und dann so oh, excuse me, und dann gehen die wieder raus, wieder davon auszugehen, dass sie kein Deutsch sprechen. Es ist im Mittenköln Apartmentanlagen, es ist einfach nervig, es ist ja für die auch schlecht und für mich ist es auch nervig, du willst ja nicht beobachtet werden, wenn du schläfst und deswegen, ich habe immer versucht, das ist ja so ein bisschen wie diese Atomleute, wo du dann, wenn du denkst, dass bitte montags nicht vor zehn reinkommen, das schreibst du an die Tür und um acht acht Uhr dreißig steht jemand in deinem Zoll und dann denkst du dir... Die Atomleute? Ich erinnere mich. Ja, weil... Das ist der Moment, wo ich dir nicht mehr folge. Ja, Atomleute, pass auf. Atommüll hat ja so Halbwertszeiten von hundert Millionen Jahren. Du meinst wegen der Anzüge. So. Imker. Nein. Das sind keine Atomleute. Nur Leute, die Atommüll vergraben. Was machen die in deiner Wohnung? Ich kann denen nicht folgen. Leute, die Atommüll vergraben, sehen sich mit der Aufgabe konfrontiert, dass sie diesen Atommüll auf eine Art kennzeichnen müssen, dass die auch in einer Million Jahren verstehen. Das YouTube-Video kenne ich. Verstehen, Achtung, hier nicht reinbeissen, du fette Sau. Deswegen haben die bei den Designern einen Contest ausgeschrieben. Ja, das erkläre ich dir doch gerade, Stefan. Das musst du mir doch nicht erklären. Die das gefährlichste Symbol machen. Richtig. Lass mich die Kurs erklären, weil das ist wirklich lustig. Weil haben die wirklich an Studenten dann so Versuche gemacht, welches das gefährlichste ist. Und überraschende Überraschung, der Teddybär ist es nicht geworden. Der kleine Teddybärgesicht und Hello Kitty ist es auch nicht geworden. Was ist es denn geworden? Der Schnuller dann doch. Am Ende ist es dann das Atomzeichen geworden.
Es sieht gefährlich aus.
Niemand weiß, was es bedeutet.
Es sieht nicht so wirklich gefährlich aus.
Aber du denkst dir auch so ein Ausrufezeichen.
Propeller, denkt man.
Ausrufezeichen ist nicht furchtanflösend so.
Achtung.
Ja, für uns, aber für jemanden so ein Alien.
Und der Totenkopf ist schon nicht schlecht, aber Aliens haben halt vielleicht einen anderen Totenkopf, die denken sich, was soll das? Das wäre deren Teddy. Oh, Teddys! Aber deswegen sah ich mich mit der Aufgabe konfrontiert, zu dieser Person, die anscheinend kein Deutsch lesen kann, irgendwie zu vermitteln, geh montags nicht vor zehn in dieses Zimmer. Und das kannst du komplett vergessen. Ich habe wirklich so einen grossen Kreis mit diesem Strich durch, was einfach so ein allgemeines Verbot. Und da habe ich eine Uhr drauf gemalt. Also, ich behaupte mal, These, wenn du das Atomzeichen mit einem Edding an deine Haustüret ist. Wäre, excuse me, excuse me, nicht mehr in das Zimmer gegangen.
Die hätten meinen Honig aufgeräumt, die hätten alle Waben sortiert, die hätten den ganzen Honig rausgewaschen.
Das wäre eine Katastrophe geworden.
Der Mensch ist darauf, nein, ja, vielleicht werden Leute mit so Scannern und diesen, wie hessen die Röntgen, nee, diese Geigerzähler mit so einem Violinzähler, wären dann reingekommen und hätten das dann ausgemessen vielleicht. Ich habe auf jeden Fall da wirklich wüste Karikaturen hingeschreit und ich habe wirklich Ausrufezeichen, Verbotsschild und ich habe eine Uhr drauf gemalt, wo ich einen gewissen Teil der Uhr markiert habe, mit ganz vielen Ausrufezeichen. Das ist nicht dein Ernst. Mit vor allem dem Finger vor dem Mund habe ich drauf gemalt. Leise sein wann? In der Zeit, die ich markiert habe. Und nächster Tag, acht Uhr dreißig, steht in meiner Wohnung. Leute, was ist hier los? Es sind zwei Archäologen, die vor diesen Zeichnungen stehen und sagen, oh, hier sehen wir diese Malen. Was haben sie damit gemeint? Ich habe es nicht hinbekommen, zu kommunizieren, dass ich alleine gelassen werde. Die sind immer reinkommen. Das sind so Arrival-artige Züge. Das ist total merkwürdig. Wie kommuniziert man mit einer Spezies, wo man nicht genau weiß, wo die herkommt? Und ich dachte irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, die müssen halt das Zimmer sauber machen, aber die sind ja immer reingekommen und haben gemerkt, oh sorry, oh sorry und sind wieder rausgegangen, wo ich gesagt habe, das hättet ihr auch schon an dem wüsten Zettel bemerken können. Keine Chance, keine Chance und so fühlen sich die ganzen Studenten, diese scheisse Studenten. Aber das finde ich interessant, ich hätte jeden Tag was anderes drauf gemalt und geguckt, wie verängstigt sie waren, als sie reingekommen sind, wie schnell sie nach dem Excuse-Mix wieder rausgegangen sind und wann sie vielleicht sogar nicht reingegangen wären. Ich glaube, wenn du so eine satanische, also diesen Kreis, den man ja kennt, vielleicht so Tierköpfe in so einer Kreisformation raufgemalt hättest und dann vielleicht in Latein geschrieben hättest, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Theus ex machina, dann hättest du vielleicht Chancen gehabt. Jetzt fällt es mir ein, ich bin sogar auf die Idee gekommen, dass ich mir dachte, ich lasse von innen
den Schlüssel stecken,
weil wenn von innen der Schlüssel
steckt, kann man von außen
den Schlüssel ja gar nicht erst reinstecken.
Also man kommt nicht rein.
Ich dachte mir, safe, alles gut,
kein Problem, schlaf ein,
nächster Tag, 8.30 Uhr,
hola, hola, hola,
dinero, dinero, was ist denn mit dir los? Spanische Gitarrenmusik, acht Uhr dreißig, hola, hola, hola, dinero, dinero.
Was ist denn mit denen los? Spanische Gitarrenmusik, ich denke mir, Leute, die brechen in die Wohnung, die haben die Tür eingetreten. Nein, die sind trotzdem reingekommen. Aber was ist denn mit denen los? Weil die müssen doch total verängstigt sein irgendwann, weil alles an der Tür sagt, der will gerade nicht, dass ich reinkomme, dieser fette Freak. Vor allem, warum hast du nicht dann irgendwann angefangen? So Bindfaden, der so Mechanismen auslöst und so eine grosse Fallbeil, wo so Achtung Fallbeil. Ja, ich dachte mir wirklich, ich stelle von innen die Tür zu, dass sie nicht die Tür öffnen können physisch. So Mäuse fallen, also eine Bärenfalle, die hinter der Tür direkt steht. Oder dass die Tür woanders hinführt, dass sie dann aus dem Haus rausfallen oder sowas.
Es war wirklich so fucking frustrierend einfach.
Aber so geht es den Steilstudenten auch, wenn in 10.000 Jahren die Leute anfangen, Atommel zu essen und die so, nein, du kriegst es nicht kommuniziert.
Excuse me, dann machen sie es wieder zu, das war's.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Ja, dann sind wir schon verstrahlt.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. Kommunikation
bleibt einfach irgendwo stecken, so. Ab einem gewissen
Punkt kriegst du es nicht vermittelt.
Nee. Du kriegst es
nicht vermittelt. Kommunikation bleibt
stecken. Ein Rätsel.
Und damit
lassen wir euch in die Woche. Vielen Dank fürs
Hören des Podcasts. Ich muss jetzt leider
noch aus Bochum nach Hause fahren. Ja.
Ich wünsche dir eine grusame Nacht, ich wünsche dir alles Gute. Ich hoffe, du kannst in dem Bett noch schlafen, obwohl ich meine Füße hier abgelegt habe.
Ich habe mir die Stelle ganz genau gemerkt, wie du deine Scheißfüße drauf hast und ich werde drum herum schlafen.
Ich sehe schon, du schielst immer zur Sagrotan-Flasche rüber, zum Sagrotan-Fass, dass du dir mitgebracht hast.
Ohrzopft ist, jetzt wird angestochen.
Sagrotan ist.
Okay, ich wünsche dir eine gute Heimreise, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wenn es wieder heisst.
Stefan hebt literally ab.
Wir heben ab.